and when that when that gets good to me
yeah I put it all my weight
when that neck gets good I'm like okay
with both sides well just banana
[Music]
guys girls are back again and you know
how we do for the very fourth time for
the very fourth time I mean just go
straight into the IG question and the
question this week was James what was
the moment you said God why me
oh before I start guys can you think of
any God why me moments and I'll run it
back and ask you after I read off my
list okay yeah all right say less cool
God why me
splitting my jeans on a first day and a
guy calling it a free pass
God why me what yeah a free pass
give me that a free pass God why me I'm
gonna say God wipe me off every single
one all right
when a thong fell out of my bag in front
of the whole class
Gods wow facts bro you said it happened
to you and not you but so I'm going
wrong it's so funny you said that I had
to uh the other night two my boys from
school came over to mine okay randomly
okay I haven't seen them in a couple
years okay
um came over to someone we were just
talking about reminiscent school we
spoke about the exact story mad go left
them overnight bro left her her bag in
class yeah the black things in the class
drapes open up I said who's this draws
for her book saw her name on it draws
the panties yeah put on a pin board oh
and we're running down the thing like
dirty panty dirty panty
bro they were Savages
wow she cried I bet she and she was a
year older than us no all right bro wow
Savage it was Savage
dirty panty
[Laughter]
it sounds like come on ladies
[Music]
oh
it's my Hazel and Reverb very very good
very very nice
oh one pound each six four five pound
one pound each wow watching bro
um when he blessed me with another
cheating boyfriend
God why me
yes when the ugly friend approached me
and I had to take one for the team
God why me we've all been there
um I don't think I've actually taken one
for the team but I've entertained
I've been to attack so much insecure I
had to these These are good at me about
this in the zoom chat the other day you
weren't even there about the the thing
that I tried to entertain and couldn't
take it anymore
yeah yeah you can't take this thing yeah
you flopped Ram's game for it yeah you
have to Bro all right literal put my
hand in front of her Tom
and said stop yeah we need to leave
that's blocked me like yeah crazy I
would never forgive myself for it but
also if it happened tomorrow I'll do it
again so all I can say is sorry in it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
mad
licked his balls during sex and woke up
with pink eye the next day God why me
Jesus this one resonates everyone my
phone fell down the side of the bed and
I couldn't reach it
that stresses me out the worst one that
happens to me is in the car it will slip
out my pockets
the teacher used my answer as an example
of what never to say
good way
what never to say that's humiliating
broke up with me and asked for Girl
advice in the same phone call
wow
that's that's she consoled him yeah yeah
she took the dump and then consoled him
for half an hour and said wow we're here
girl advice yeah where where did I go
wrong with you and where did I go right
wow
when my stalker gave me chocolate in
front of my friend
she didn't want any parts of it oh wow I
laughed at something mouth wide open and
a seagull in my mouth that's impossible
it probably isn't that's impossible bro
bro I I think I would burn my throat yes
it went in my mouth because I know them
things land hot as well
if I was talking to you and I laughed
and the thing went in my mouth I'll be
staring at you Mom shaking just dripping
yeah it'll be like foaming out my mouth
I promise you the thing is what's Matt
is that you would laugh now my initial
reaction would be to rock your Jorah
you don't understand the anger I'd feel
I'll go berserk for your head
wow
that's my worst thing no I know I know
anyone who loves is getting bombed
bombed with your mouth
yeah yeah my jaw rotate to the top oh
you're chewing yuck yuck
I woke up to my ex standing over me
after we broke up
standing over me after we broke up that
was scary scary
woke up to my date sucking my toes
again scary but it depends what you're
feeling yeah if I woke up to my date so
I can something
yeah
my reason eyebrow yeah I might have
raised both
[Laughter]
when I was cleaning my mom's room and I
found her two-sided dildo
I've never cleaned my mom's room in my
life this is have you yeah when I was a
kid yeah sure back in the day my my
chores were who videoed and like tidy my
sister's chores was laundry and dishes
yeah mine those are exactly the same as
mine but my my mom's room just she just
never asked us to do it this is probably
why
it's probably why there's probably
demons in there bro
fair play fair play he asked me to be
his girl at the end of the third date
when I was going to call it off
tough
um tough
oh I called her and she answered while
she was getting banged then try to call
me back all out of breath
nah bro
yeah yeah that all out of breath is like
hello
yeah hello I couldn't answer before I
was you know I was busy but
yeah I'm back now what's what's up
just panting
nah bro why are you out of breath
it's muddy because all she'd hear from
me is breathing back that's all she'd
hear from me she knows I'm livid yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to suss what
I'm gonna do and what I can get away
with yeah
accident accidentally just getting
banged and then don't you dare call me
back
you know what I heard yeah out of breath
bro oh because you know you've never
made her outbreak yeah that's the worst
thing oh that's the insecurities she
calls her mom straight after we bang oh
my days composed
composed nah all out of breath
oh that's because she was doing that
squat one yeah yeah yeah the knees
rotating wow wow wow wow wow my client's
apartment was covered in blood I'm a
mental health support worker he wasn't
injured
walking in
and you you're just unscathed yeah nah
God why me yeah let's try out
when he was on top of me during 69 this
guy put his [__] on my face
why was he why'd you let him on top
why'd you let him on top that's
aggressive also a reverse 69 a 96 a 96
is an aggressive bro I'm heavy I'm
talking heavy right I'm On Top heavy and
when that when that gets good to me yeah
I put all my way behind it
just banana
[Music]
see me come on yeah
I'm up for air that's jokes when it's
getting good
oh
you're forces oh Jesus that's so funny
bro hilarious that's hilarious
when the DJ cuts the B mid song to let
the crowd sing and I find myself
screaming The Wrong lyrics
man there's been a couple of times I've
been in someone's car like yours or
someone else's and I'm just vibing the
looks under my breath yeah the lyrics
you know from the lyrics I know I catch
myself saying the wrong things and I
I feel like I just farted and I'm
waiting for you to consult me about it
or to do something yeah yeah wait for
you to confront me about it yeah yeah I
feel like I just did a semi silent bar I
heard it pop a little bit yeah and I'm
waiting for you to be like what did you
do yeah what was that yeah facts yeah
I'm waiting bro I hate when that happens
especially when there's a bait song yeah
it's embarrassing it's so embarrassing
for embarrassing
when the lady at the checkout closed the
till after her helping the person in
front of me
no that's a cause for fight
of course and ten percent
never again
when I found him cheating again and I
cried in his arms
not a God why me that's you're forcing
yourself yeah she had no strength though
she she fell into yeah yeah wow she had
no strength that's he quote cheating
will will strip you yeah he will bury
you same thing when my boys was coming
over the other day I forgot when I was a
you I got cheated on oh
um by my hey I've told this story on
here before I don't know about my 18
year old girlfriend yes
cheating on me yeah yeah uni boyfriend
number two teams
fam yeah it took everything from me I
don't even know why I care that much but
it just took everything from me
punched my car bro I punched my car and
had to catch myself for fall into my
knees
I remember
[Laughter]
as I cast myself on the Bonnet bro
foreign
I remember because I was blind to the
fact that I was getting cheated on oh of
course and I remember
you made it painfully obvious it was a
time when she had this the love bite and
I was I was playing huhu haha about the
whole thing I remember she wore a turtle
fan
I remember when I S when I saw it and
clocked out I explained it to you man I
was like oh fam when you said it out
loud oh yeah that's what we'll be doing
bro what we actually do what did you say
it was again I don't know she said it
was something else I don't remember bro
I just I just didn't want to hear it
James I just didn't want to hear it I
was a Broken Man
I couldn't believe it I was giving them
ayal uh I remember the same way you were
talking about buying a bag for like a
grand did I or was that yes you did for
Christmas really and I remember we were
on our phone I said what did you say
because you was like oh the bag's like
1100 pounds and we didn't have 1100
pounds
are we sure we talk about the same chick
yes bro okay okay okay I don't remember
this bro I'm not gonna lie to you I was
in a phase that I could have said
anything to you do you know you were
doing the most yeah yeah yeah I love you
[__] loved her and I'll never forgive
her for that you [__] loved her bro I
would never forgive her for that that's
why Jason is on site in it
he said his hands if he sees her if he
sees there's on site that's hilarious
that's hilarious she hurt you bro I will
never ever forgive her bro it's mad it's
actually mad bro wow my boy was broken I
was down in the dumps I was literally on
the floor oh I know you was on a
pavement yeah the floor I was at a
[__] pavement
wow on the streets of North if I mean of
all places Northampton pavement vomiting
and crying nah not my voice bro
a couple more um God why me a mosquito a
mosquito bit me on my lip the night
before the first day of the new year at
school
yes rap to Bro on a herpes thing it's
wrapped wrapped bro that's a that is one
million percent of God by me yes bro you
can't get away from that one million
percent a God why me
last one my family was bad and I would
wreck my car within a week I ran into a
poll on day seven
I'm staying away until the week's past
oh facts facts I'm not touching you yeah
and I'll say someone vandalized it I'm
not touching the car
um but yeah um yeah so God why me
moments Ellis first thing what came to
mind was I was on a first day oh yeah
and um but it was it was before the date
so
I used to be on like acne medication
okay tablets and stuff okay and um dude
I don't want to say it dude honestly
yeah they're Grim they've got like um
these ones
continue Alice I'm so sorry yeah
um and they have like um it's like fish
oil in like they're Grim but apparently
that helps with stuff yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then literally took one of them
on the morning I was meeting at like 12
or something I was like cool go shop
went shop
was walking back and I could feel
something repeated on you I could feel
something like in my throat
the [__] this oh
like that and it literally like powder
of the tablet just just like
regurgitated didn't throw up though it
just went like there way yeah genuinely
so obviously it's like cod liver oil
when started inside so it was just like
fit like honestly
yeah everywhere and I was like [__]
sake so I think I'll like run back try
to like freshen up as best as I could
yeah still went and then for the whole
day because we went to like a restaurant
and I was just like felt sick the whole
day like I couldn't eat so I was just I
literally just just sat there just like
this is [__] wow
honestly it was horrible
wow you're lucky
I'm glad it happened before coming out
fine I would think you're a [__] I
don't know yeah but I never took him
again after that yeah I was done yeah
um God why me
um no ramps yeah I probably do you
probably do if we if you actually get
this I'll [__] cry
um back when I was a support worker
yeah when I was a support worker back in
the day working with kids um autistic uh
bipolar
um learning difficulties
um autism
there was a kid there
and we used to work with them one to one
and yeah obviously lunchtime this one
particular kids we used to have to feed
him
and so I was feeding him his yogurt
and
in the process of me feeding him his
yogurt
he either used to like hit out your hand
so you have to be careful of that but
what I forgot on with this particular
client is that he he likes to spit as
well
so I accidentally caught a stray in my
mouth one time from this kid who I was
feeding the yogurt too and that's
probably the lowest point I've ever been
in my entire life wow
I don't prop I promise you bro I don't
care about health and safety I don't
care about rules and regulations I would
retaliate yeah and it won't it won't
even be like me doing it it will be
innate do you know what I mean facts
yeah I would just as soon as I feel it
Bang Yeah
and I'll squeeze his mother and spit
I'll drink it y'all gonna spin this
baseball
again
do Improv
you better not tell any [__] nonsense
[Music]
and you squeeze is so tight because you
can't do anything else laundry room oh
yeah I was screaming you're a real man
Bros
continue the shift and just wow
yeah that's the second I'll drop my
badge
wow wait what did you have though for me
mine before I even said that yeah I
didn't even know what yours could have
been but when you said that I was like
no way you're you're King Javan
that's a God why me
being given uh yeah yeah
she spun you yeah she did I forgot about
Javan she spun to both of you yeah man
with chips and eat chocolate during that
before you yeah she was ahead of the car
she was actually ahead of the game girl
one doing that they weren't wow giving
bread next man's number yeah so text me
and we were actually texting
each other um why me I couldn't think of
one literally until you said the
mosquito bite before the first day of
school
brother when I moved to North obviously
I didn't have a barber I didn't have any
connects to Barbers so my mom one day
just brought me to one Barber
and my hair was long bro when I say I
hadn't had my hair cut we moved to North
in like
mid-march yeah and they decided or maybe
beginning of March and basically the
school were like oh he might as well
stay off until end of April yeah until
after Easter
so last you were joining at the end of
the term yeah so I joined straight after
Easter holidays
so my hair was long bro and when I say
long I don't mean a little bit long yeah
I mean like an actual afro long oh swear
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like long like
afro comb everything I swear yeah fam so
she's she says to me uh woman at work
suggested this barber in town can't
think that she takes her son to so we're
gonna go down thinking gang bro gang
um so uh I'll take you there so I had to
start school with a nappy head top
so I went there got the haircut and
first red flag he didn't have a mirror
in front of the chair
he didn't have a mirror in front of the
chair so I sat down obviously obviously
at seven I was nervous I'm not telling
him what I want yeah my mom told him
what yeah what I want bro
come out the thing I thought he just
patterned me no mirror no mirror bro
scary hours Sam I thought he patented me
I was just grateful to get a haircut
yeah
I must have left
got in the car
man had given me a
picture-perfect mini afro
Picture Perfect microphone bro
sprayed and glistening this a Bruno
Master he'd literally give me a perfect
one
I was like no no no no no no no no no no
my mom was like that looks nice bro I
had to go to school the next day well I
remember one prayer called Perry he
couldn't keep his mouth shut if I'm a
sous award Tim myself what did you ask
for
he was lean up against the wall crying
and I said he ordered us for mini afro
I was like no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
no he was betting
he was grabbing my boys grabbing my boys
look look man that's the mini afro
bro my Ting was shining perfect I was
[__] livid I was like mum take me
back bro I'm not paying for another
haircut wait till it grows out it looks
nice bro worst two weeks of my [__]
life
what's the reason my life
a random have you ever had your hair
braided no
no
never in a million years the reason why
I was because obviously you said you had
afro before so I don't know no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
I'll probably say my God why me moment
is um
when I actually said this um on
um what's that thing called
um
[__] you know what's it called pasta
makeup
um when I nearly got my phone robbed
Oh by Donald yeah so I've actually I
actually forgot about that story until I
kind of what we spoke about that
triggered that story's coming to my head
I forgot that even happened so I was in
year nine maybe
um
I was in London coming I was on holiday
from school in Nigeria it was me my boy
and two girls we were going to one of
their one of the girls houses somewhere
on road and a guy in the back is an
adult bro on a bike just started
circling this is in Nigeria no this we
won Holiday from now so school holidays
but you're back in England I was gonna
say that sounds terrifying all right
because I wouldn't be on road like that
yeah I'm not gonna lie to you that's off
ends yeah
um so a guy on this bike was like oh
have any of you got the time I was like
no I didn't have a watch no no watch
sorry my bro
um he's like
no let me see your phone now let me see
your phone let me see if I was like oh
bro don't do this man don't and it's one
of those ones where you can't
obviously he's a grown man on a bike
yeah he's a grown-ass man on a bike
that's a trouble bro that's trouble
number one yeah yeah you know what I
mean full bid and everything I was
thinking Jesus Christ
um I'm not I don't know what to say
because I've never been in this
situation yeah and I'm looking at I'm
looking at my boy and he's looking at me
and I'm looking at the girls they're
like 10 steps ahead and they're looking
at me and I'm thinking I ain't got a
phone my Bros I don't even ask you again
let me see that phone
and that was the man I was like God yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah showed him the
phone 8210 Nokia he kissed his teeth and
handed it back to me he didn't want it
so I don't want this [__] it's not worth
it it's not worth the hassle wow that's
embarrassing yeah sprinted to the odd oh
I bet let's go let's go bro I can't come
back again I never went back to the ends
again
probably like Cricket water sign like
Northwest
so stupid like that never went back
there again I was a child oh yeah man
um guys answer in the comments what is
your most God why men why men why me
family God why men would yeah
God why me that would run answer in the
comments
okay guys welcome back to the show we
are very very grateful to have you here
with us today episode 281 of shits in
gigs and if you are a fan if you're a
Super Fan if you would dare call
yourself a cult baby please act like it
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs and please
contribute uh measly three pound a month
MP a day run the P to S and G and
indoctrinate yourself into the culture
into the cult itself on our Discord
Channel meet and greet everyone in the
community get first dibs on live shows
first dibs on merch first lives on
literally everything as well as jumping
on a call with me and fuhad as a group
to discuss everything cult baby okay if
you're watching us on YouTube guys
please please please please please
please I can't say it enough please
subscribe to the Channel please actually
do it please it means the world to us
and
um like the video chirp to sing in the
comment man we need the breeding grounds
on and pop in and uh guys if you listen
to us if you love The Sweet Caramel
voices in your ear every Monday
listen clearly now leave a five-star
review but that's all I'm asking five
star review you might not mean it but
just do it just do it I'm tired of
asking
um and guys without any further Ado I
think we're going to go into top five
top five top five top five top five top
five top five we are indeed gotta go top
five top five I'm ready is Ellie's gonna
catch a break today
um it's it's tentative
the thing is the thing is I actually
didn't forget I was actually searching
for game related quizzes but I feel like
let me do a bit more research so when we
come back from La the next one we do
will be getting all right cool all right
so this top five
is there's not an actual top five but we
still call it top five
it is top five most commonly misspelled
words oh my
you're banned bro why am I bad you're a
band
it's not gonna be done hard bro
you normally misspelled whatever it's
not gonna be like Arachnophobia or some
[__] like it's they're regular words
bro so it's done yeah
relax bro relax you never know I mean
I'm Gonna Catch the dub but I'm saying
that sister actually what I like
all right cool you might not leave it
from the jump and then one of you are
going to be screaming at you're the
winner soon so it's all good
it's all good man it's so good first
word so I
as you know I'm gonna say the word each
of you are going to try and spell it
right right on the board and then eat
after each round you spell it out to be
right or wrong simple oh is that what
we're doing oh what do you think it was
so you're gonna give us the word you're
actually trying to spell these oh you
thought that's what I'm saying the whole
English language and you're like which
ones are the most misspelled
to be fair I didn't think that but like
I still thought it was a kind of a long
shot game to be fair
oh bro I'm gonna say words you're gonna
spell it for me
I don't understand did you think yeah I
thought I thought literally what are the
five four the whole English dictionary
that's what I thought no first of all
I'm going off what you said you said the
top five most commonly Miss belt words
what did I say before that I said it's
not an actual top five but I'm still
gonna say top five and then I said top
five most Miss comedy um most comedies
misspelled words I just think it was
because you said you didn't think it was
what he said and you didn't think it was
what I said no I thought he was going to
read some some words off
oh that were like unbelievably hard yeah
and then we would then just happen
because you thought you were just going
to get me to write words no no bro what
word are we living in exactly bro that's
why I'm moaning there's one thing I
might be doing this that's why I said
your band though this is boring now no
bro all right cool yeah you're you're
invested now yeah I'm here I'm here I'm
gonna get it wrong and I'm livid about
it all right the first word the first
word is maneuver
okay
I mean I couldn't even spell Australia
oh yeah yeah that's what it spurred off
wasn't it no yeah
I've been thinking about this one for a
minute to be fair all right you give me
yours first sped out for me maneuver
m-a-n-u-e-v-o-u-r-e
Alice m-a-n
-o-u-v-e-r close but wrong Jimmy
m-a-n-o-u-v-r-e
very close but wrong really what is it
so is what did you say by the way
did you say by the way don't point at me
like that fam put your finger down now
never do that ever again these are
nowhere I sit in the studio fan you
don't need to point at me
I said it may end yeah u e yeah
I was literally missing the E that was
it all right cool now you're missing
more than one you were missing more than
one I was listening you were missing too
I was deep in it cool I was deep enough
but this one spun me as well because I
tend to get this wrong quite a bit
broccoli okay
oh
oh it's the I know I know which one will
spin people all right what do you want
to write [__] ah I know it's gonna spin
me again broccoli
man-made veg
spell it man-made veg is it man-made
that's artificial
what Brooklyn is awesome it's
artificially made you don't like plant
broccoli seeds or whatever so how'd you
make it I know it's made in a lab or
something no let me Google it broccoli
is man-made uh contrary to the claims of
some Skeptics broccoli is not
genetically modified or man-made
vegetable is a naturally occurring plant
that belongs to the same family as kale
cabbage and cauliflower
also I had to Google it but I promise
you now I spelled it right I spelled it
right I spelled it right before I
Googled it I used my pen since I spelled
it right you're a cheat and now I've
actually shown my my voice
why is it void do we because you believe
it I should because you showed you I
showed my answer to YouTube that's why
I've already written it yeah I've
already got mine did you how did you
spit it so I bought b r
all right
what that's your signature
immediately that's our right man that's
how I write I'm right small that's all
right turn around
can you read BR no oh there's even there
I can see you in there c c o u
come around the cameras
that's what you are Ellis I've never
seen anything like it
[Applause]
he said to you
I've I definitely did not expect that
list that's right yeah that was
hilarious
wow okay so it's a black smudge since
everyone wrote an answer down I will
give uh James and REM the point for
broccoli next one bureaucracy yeah Jimmy
hit me spell it b-e-u-r-o-c-r-a-c-y
wrong Ram
b-e-a-u-r-o-c-r-a-c-y wrong Ellis
b-e-a-u-r-o-c
and then this one would r c y wrong yeah
what is it b u all of you said be yeah
says b u r e a u c r a c y bureaucracy
that's a silly silly word next next next
next
liquify all right you go first when I
lock in l i
c q u i f y
wrong damn it Alice l-i-q-u
ID
f y
you didn't hear the word he didn't hear
the word he can't have he wouldn't put a
D in there oh I get a Liquid Fire yeah
yeah that's how I spell it liquidify it
I spell a liquid fiber okay that's not
as bad as a fan
you're looking at your boss we all look
at each other
oh god I've just gone for
l-i-q-u-i-f-i say again
l-i-q-u-i-f-i unfortunately you're wrong
I'm gonna say it is l i
q u
what did you say you said CK's I said c
cubed and that was my gamble and I've
actually written liq but it's gone l i q
u e f y
did you put an i at the end of it yeah
yeah because I knew it was going to be
risque I just do that we're going to try
and [__] with us yeah I just didn't
think it would be the E all right so as
it stands James won REM won Ellis nil
one more there's one more oh God this is
Harsh man last one we can't spell
but these are the toughest words
literally saying we're basic [__]
commoners okay full full uh honesty did
you know how to spell these words when
you're written down like if I've never
spelled my life the other words as well
that we've done um
all my life I would have gone maneuver I
would have forgotten I would not have
gotten broccoli I would have gone
because I've had to type that in bear
times because I always get wrong right
and the last one I'm gonna say I
probably would have gotten wrong okay
cool
um and the last word is connoisseur
Connor sir
with confidence yeah do you know what
spinos Peak I'm writing them with
confidence I'm writing them QuickTime
fan but they're all wrong it's not
making any difference oh you've got one
right yeah I guess all right Jimmy let's
go with you
I'm gonna go with
written it down twice and I'm picking
which one I think it looks better
c-o-n-o-s-s-u-e-r-e
incorrect REM c o n n o i s s e u r
that's [__] fantastic well I played
we got it what is it again c o n n o i s
s e u r
well [__] but you wrote that quick as
well well [__] played thank you
Ellie show me the ball you've been
calling yourself that to someone I'm
cultural like that
that's wrong bro yeah yeah
well please
zero he's told nine people he's a kind
of stuff
called bad times bro well played Ram
yeah thank you thank you yeah man uh
yeah because I still till now you've
said it three times I couldn't repeat it
I still don't know what it is fair fair
so that would be total scores is that
three three in total yeah in total I
think it's three three four four three
zero oh four three zero oh was it four
two last week yeah it was fourteen okay
cool cool cool cool
that was um top five so we're gonna do
um thing is next time yeah we're gonna
do games next week games next week yeah
nice all right say let's say let's say
less yeah man all right ping okay cool
well
before we continue
I think food has got a thread for us I
do I've got a little thread of like a
little little lighting something just
just to touch the surface this is my new
John by the way disliking it's good
the hips yeah you do need to stretch out
your hips mum this is good it's good
all right quick Fred
things that your ex said that
flabbergasted you oh god I've got a few
of these I'll swear oh no oh from my
life oh okay
I love you but I love other people too I
can't help it
I can't help it
this is just text after text after text
after text just stop you talk too much
you always complain that you have zero
energy yet you talk forever and ever I
don't care
wow
I don't compliment you because I would
be dishonest
I can remarry but no one will want you
because you have a child okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
I can be very affectionate towards
someone if I really like them so I'm
sorry if I didn't feel like that with
you but again that ain't my fault
it's your fault if I don't like you like
that that's your fault it's not my fault
mine cheated on me and then recommended
me a self-help book
wow if you didn't want to be upset you
shouldn't have looked at your phone you
did that to yourself
Jesus bro yeah bro these men are just
gone in when you dress like that it's
like you're disrespecting me
that was the last one wow it's like your
disrespecting me
yeah that was a quick fight yeah people
people treat relationships like property
they do they think they can say what
they want they do wow oh yeah this right
so it's a bag bro you get that crack
here it's a bag I feel it crack my knees
and then my hip cracks here it's so good
I'm old as tits bro
um right so we've got uh update uh not
even an update or I can do the update
now oh so
um I was gonna do trash news right
this is see how last week with the what
do I say bro
yeah this is um
this is that for me okay what to say bro
trash news Indonesian man had to undergo
emergency surgery after breaking his
penis performing the world's most
dangerous sex position I'm gonna skip to
the end this reverse cowgirl what a
saved bro reverse cowgirl first position
it's the worst position it is because it
bends and breaks tools if it clearly is
the most it's rated most dangerous bro
bro these lot didn't want to hear it
when I said it on here before when we
said it on here before I didn't want to
hear it these guys that's not doing it
right shut up it's bending it's bending
and it's breaking it's bending and it's
bending and it's breaking you man can't
do what you think you can do but we just
firm it fast because we love you don't
reverse it
don't flip it and reverse it look at me
when you ride it look at me when you
ride it I want to see you and squeeze
you definitely don't lay on your front
definitely don't try that
Oh my days yeah reverse cowgirl it it's
um it's a deadly deadly position it is
deadly deadly deadly and that's so yeah
unless you're an apex predator you can't
do it right yeah yeah stop pretending
bro because he's just firming yeah he is
he is it hurts man but
I actually can't remember the last time
I did it
sit full disclosure yeah I've done it a
few times yeah since we've had that
conversation yeah and it's it's
patterned up okay it passes because
you're like psyche is like I can't let
um because you kind of have to
um I kind of had to just like
I just wasn't gonna be used anymore okay
I wasn't gonna be used anymore and I had
to stand up for myself
I wasn't going to be treated like that
yeah so your boy had to get creative
okay so we like so the reverse is
patterned but your boy instead of laying
flat like this with it using my legs as
leverage yeah and then my tour is like
the blood forces are there and the
door's straight up already your boy had
to open his legs up a little bit okay so
you have to open your legs up yeah and
then it gives you the rotation yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but we need yeah I need to be able to
follow so yeah do you know what I mean
yeah and then we can if we're feeling
crazy and then um and then I can hide
you here and I can get you here
and then and then I can get here and
then if I need to we can Kamasutra yeah
I can sit up and I can like Jujitsu yeah
and I can I can do what I want to you
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's all about
the knees yeah it's all in the knees is
all in the knees so don't let it do what
she wants yeah it's all in the knees
I've literally not done it but yeah if
you're not long and strong I don't know
what to do you might have to just firm
it and he's just been up bro
um
but yeah um yeah girls shut up you don't
know what you're doing up there and it's
not fair to us it is literally the most
dangerous Exposition we've said it
before and no one wants to hear it all
right so I'm gas that came out I'm sorry
for homeboy yeah but gas that came out
because I got abusive DMS after after we
said that abusive DMS obviously always
from women I didn't see a single guy
confront me say like oh you're a liar
bro no no no no she's not doing it wrong
but my girl knows how to do it no one
said that because they know the truth it
was all girls like nah they're not doing
it right I know how to you don't know I
never mind your man's in his bed crying
yeah he's he's owning an army because
you're breaking his dick over an orange
he's weeping inside he's weeping inside
um but anyway you've got attraction as
well no spiritual leader Dalai Lama
apologized to a young boy and his family
following a video showing that um
Tibetan spiritual Guru kissing the boy
and instructing him to suck his tongue
only only over the weekend did a video
become widely shared online sparking
um Sparky indignation as many users
Express shock at the inappropriate
behavior obviously others were expressed
others expressed worry that the esteemed
guest in the video were clapping and
laughing in the background without
attempting to Halt the situation I'm
obviously not going to show you well I'm
going to show you the video but we're
not going to show the video
it's a video no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
bro wow
situation these men are in for this to
be happening and he's
um The Daily Numbers actually tweeted a
video clip has been circulating that
shows a recent meeting when a young boy
asked his Holiness Dalai Lama if he
could oh he didn't tweet a place on his
account so someone tweeted on his behalf
yeah it's a fan he's like 900 years old
I wasn't thinking he was tweeting it and
he told us if he could give him a hug
his Holiness his Holiness wishes to
apologize to the boy in his family as
well as his friends across the world for
his hurtful words that could have caused
um his owners often teases people he
meets in an innocent playful way even if
cameras are there he regrets the
incident
his lips everything bro
the whole thing is suspect yeah bro if
that was my you
I'm I'm gassed at my you gets to meet
the Dalai Lama
and then I'm just see he just grabs his
chin and says that that I don't know
they're saying about it so invasive
I'm glad he's coming here
and the boy's hesitant at first because
the boy backs up yeah and then like does
the thing and the fingers as well
I'm not gonna lie to you bro that boy
looks like five years old six years old
when I'm six and some old ass Masters
saying I say Suck it probably suck it
I'm not gonna lie if you don't know you
don't know what you're doing and I'm on
stage yeah yeah you're looking for your
parents bam is this okay is this okay
you're looking for your parents you
don't know the peakest thing is if my
man's comfy doing that on camera oh off
camera what's he doing everything
everything's getting sucked what's
normal to him off cam if that was if
that was a [__] and banter yeah on cam
in front of all those people
my girl couldn't say that and me not
hesitate what suck my tongue yeah just
in the kitchen
do you know what I mean just sit in the
kitchen the love of my life couldn't be
like my tongue no what yeah fat what are
you on about yeah yeah that's that's two
yeah literally two out of some old ass
massive suck it
suck my tongue oh my God
[Music]
all right moving swiftly so guys right
let me pull it up bro same again it's
time for that Masa right so developments
where did I leave off so last time we
spoke Okay cool so we spoke about Josh
and Melissa they're gone yeah because
Melissa is a sex crazed Maniac I spoke
about Harrison
um getting a girl's number and blaming
it on Dan we spoke about Shannon and
Caitlyn gone because Shannon said you're
just buzz so them are not gone right so
we've had a couple new people introduced
so we've had
um what's the the horrible [__] with
the tags bro Taylor
um and her man is Hugo Hugo
Taylor she's a piece of work bro yeah so
when she was interviewing the experts
they're saying where have you gone in
relationships she just said I just break
man down like I'm just so abusive they
just they just lose themselves and they
lose their power
bro she said it and she was like it's
just what I'm on and I just can't help
it I don't like being this way but yeah
I just I just I just take everything
from them wow I found this exactly what
she did wow she saw homeboy in day one
and was just like oh
day night one the on the honeymoon the
the bed's massive yeah massive bed he
said so what's the sleeping situation do
you want to do like a little pillow wall
yeah and she was like joking you're on
the sofa big man and he was like fam the
sofa's like this big stuff it's over
smaller than Sofia got that
and he's like no no no no no no no no
like I can't sleep by this and she was
like you can though and he said bro if
the bed's massive like yeah come on come
on come on and she was like
she was thinking are you playing up to
the cameras get your ass on the sofa
like I'm not playing this game fam and
then they had a little padded window
sealing you know one of those windows
she was like oh that's big I sleep on
that message is freezing it's freezing
Taylor please I'm not entertaining such
conversation I've met you this morning
first and foremost literally she said
sleep on that so the next morning if I'm
he said I didn't get any sleep except on
a freezer windowsill no I found they
went they went and played Polo the next
day
um and she said oh this is for for this
is this is for sleeping rights again
this is for the bed yeah yeah a man said
say less yeah she beat him and she was
like cool so I've got the bed and he was
like yeah you got to bed tonight she was
like tonight I've got the bed for the
whole thing he said what do you mean the
whole thing the whole experiment this
whole marriage thing as long as it lasts
I've got the bed what are we talking bro
as long as it lasts I've got the bed bro
and he's like obviously I'm not agreeing
to that she was like it's been agreed
Michael yeah we should cut it stay on
that window yeah don't chat to me again
wow fan mad and then they went to the
dinner she loves the cook up drama boy
they were on their way to the dinner and
she was like it could get heated it
could get heated and he's like why
because they've never even really met
anyone else oh yeah she was like yeah
yeah they're brand new yeah yeah this is
the first number could get heated yeah
and he's like what do you mean bro like
why would it get heated like what's
going on what are you trying to do and
she was like I don't know bro and she
was like I don't know like you just chat
a lot in it you chat she said to him to
Rupert she said you just chat too much
and sometimes when you choose
okay Hugo sorry to Hugo you just chat
too much and obviously she said in her
vows the one thing I can't handle is not
being backed up by my partner in public
if I I'm in Smoke I don't care who's
right or wrong back me so she's saying
you chat too much and sometimes when
people chat too much people need to step
in so if anyone steps in
I'm rocking up and he's like nah bro
it's a dinner party chill as soon as we
got there
this is when it moves in now yeah as
soon as we get there now
oh hell's breaking loose because now
Claire has finally told Jesse that she
lips Adam oh okay because finally told
Jessie episodes
bro this was episode like 15 or 16.
um
and she's finally told Jessie look at
lips Adam Jesse broke down I bet because
obviously like I said they Gaslight him
the whole time for two weeks bro they
Gaslight him poor Jesse bro and then um
it's so giant because I don't know if
he's staying or leaving yet the next
episode is the commitmentary and I
needed to sleep last night but bear in
mind I couldn't see it last night
anyways I should have watched it yeah um
but anyway
Claire Jesse
she's told him he confronts Adam Adam
was Defensive at first I told you he
come out and said say what you want to
say yeah yeah and Jesse's like you know
what I want to say and he's like I don't
know what you're talking about if you
want to say something to me say
everything say everything what's true or
false
um
so
all dust come up and down he he tells
Janelle who's his wife look
our lips but the way he told her he'd
come back in the room and Janelle's like
what's all this drama because Jesse had
him up in the corridor so he comes back
in the room and then um General's like
what's going on no what's all this beef
and he's like bro they found out our
lips Claire in it and she's like
what yeah and in the cameraman burst it
yeah yeah and he's like [__] so he sits
on that look right cool you know that
timer he's like but you remember we were
in a bad place right she was like what
he's like yeah we were in a bad place
anyway obviously she asked me for one of
the Vape ends up lips in minor it wasn't
really a thing yeah and she was like
cool get your stuff and move out yeah
she cried for about an episode and then
she said get your stuff move the [__]
out he said say less but he moved out
yeah
she went in on Smoke on the dinner party
she's dressed all in black
blood red lipstick Chopsticks in her
hair ready yeah she's Asian by the way
she came here she came she came to full
smoke and she was like I feel like a bad
[__] tonight I could I could imagine it
fam I feel like a bad [__] tonight she
wasn't she did a glass clinking thing as
soon as she all sat down she was like I
just need everyone's attention
damn I need everyone's attention sit
down Adam explain yourself Adam and
Claire explain yourselves to everyone
now
farm and the worst thing is I feel for
Jesse because Jesse is not on smart he
got his heart broken and he just wants
the world to eat him up yeah so he's
sitting there like why are you doing all
this God why me yeah facts God why
throwback you're getting really good at
these callbacks God why me God why me
he's thinking just swallow me whole bro
pause and don't want to be here like
you're you're drawing attention to my
name and I don't need it yeah so anyway
she's like Adam Claire explain yourself
right now
so Adam's like look
Jesse he focused purely on Jesse he
didn't chat to his wife he said Jesse to
be fair we gaslit you we lied to your
face for weeks yeah I'm sorry bro that
was [__] up I'm sorry the lips was
nothing but [__] me we Gaslight you
Jesus you went through it you were
bringing gifts to my yard
and I'm sorry you were bringing gifts to
my yard and I was texting your [__]
saying keep your mouth shut
I'm sorry bro I'm not proud of it but it
is what it is proud of it and then he's
probably very proud and then uh and
everyone's like so welcome to your wife
bro Janelle's over there he said listen
yeah me and her we weren't really on
nothing back then we found he said look
there was stuff that was happening
between us words were said on the
honeymoon we really went in a bad place
the last two weeks since the lips we've
been in a relationship and I would never
chew on her now back then I can't even
call it cheating yeah because I didn't
even like the [__] oh my God she Lean
Forward said you bang me that night
you buy me that night you liar liar
that's that guilt [__] bro she said you
lips Claire and you came home and banged
me and then everyone was like is that
true oh and he said good not of in fact
he was sussery
obviously it's not stood up family who
sat down I was just like that and then
uh who's the American singing again the
Mormon thing uh Alyssa Alyssa jumped in
and said is yes or no big man did you
bang her or not yeah and he was like
technically yes but she says there's no
buts you banged it your lips are you
banged her and he was like ah these men
don't want to listen to me Jesse come
outside they don't want to listen to me
Jesse you know don't bring my name into
this bro he said Jesse come outside and
need to chat you they don't want to hear
me yeah she's spinning lies you just
admitted that you're not like she's not
lying bro crazy crazy crazy so
um anyway Claire wrote him a long letter
Claire was remorseful okay she was
crying and said I'm sorry to Jesse I'm
so sorry yeah ran in the toilet vomiting
everything I'm so sorry how can I do
this to you oh [__] Jesse's like it's
calm he spotted her she did a
long-winded apology and afterwards all
the girls hate her as well facts so
after she's taken all the hate and I
apologize apologizing I'm gonna say we
gave her a quick spot what does that say
less I appreciate that she wrote a long
letter said please I just don't leave
Harrison I don't know what Harrison's on
yeah so Harrison was the previous cheat
yes yes was Gaslight and Bronte yes bro
I don't know what he's on yeah but he's
he's instigating stuff so he's going
over to Jesse like bro I know this is
bad but she's apologized I just don't
want you man to ruin this experiment and
Jesse's like what do you care bro yeah
like just leave me alone yeah and he's
like come come come come he says to Adam
bro you're not even remorseful bro
you're not even lawful Adam's like
pardon don't chat to me bro I'm trying
to chat to Jesse Yeah
even remorseful bro like you're just
saying stuff yeah yeah yeah and then
Harrison's supposed to be Adam's boy
okay he's supposed to be Adam's boy
to be fair Harrison's apology to Jesse
was legit he said bro I'm not gonna lie
Harrison was my boy so I it's just in my
nature to believe him me and you weren't
really boys and he's my boy so if he
said he didn't do it didn't even [__]
do it yeah yeah I'm gonna ride for him
turns out he did do it okay my bad okay
um so he was like Adam [__] you bro like
you're not even remorseful you need to
tell your wife this is this and then oh
what's her name the girl who can't stand
Melinda can't stand for nothing but
Linda jumped in and said Harrison yeah
Harrison who are you bro Linda's the one
I said [__] me [__] me [__] me no that's
me okay Linda is with Leighton
um Melinda is the one who barely spoken
about because she's not cooking up too
much okay okay Melinda basically can't
sit through stuff okay she can't just
hear stuff okay and she has to jump in
you can literally see her bite in her
fingers she has to jump in okay and um
and she basically said Harrison like
either you've just done a full 1 8 on
your personality or you're cooking up
something
um because just last week you were doing
this this this you weren't taking
accountably for nothing okay his answer
was the cleanest
paying his answer any ways man can give
anyone while I was like okay set up the
whole scenario say her bit and then say
it's been trailer so she said Harrison
from where I'm sitting is either your
lying and manipulating again or your
personality is on a full 180 bro because
just last week you were Gaslight and
Bronte you weren't taking accountability
you were getting girls numbers you got a
Ting outside and now all of a sudden
you're trying to play matchmaker talking
about please don't leave I'm so sorry
you're not taking accountability bloody
bloody bloody blah so wild one and he
said to be fair calm is a cucumber
brother
to be fair I've been trying really hard
this week and I'm very happy you noticed
the change thank you
fam she sat back in the seat and was
like raw there's nothing I can at all
the smoke he said I'm glad you've
noticed the chain thank you very much
accept it
push him bro I don't know how he gets a
safe yeah
don't ever say to me again I'm glad just
change bro I've done a full 1A of course
I [__] yeah I have thanks for noticing
wow wow I'm gonna change mine okay shut
your mouth she said Barbara okay okay
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah I deserved it
deserved it that's I just want to learn
to keep my mouth shut that's a good
Circle so we had in this we had a little
bit a little bit of drama between our
beautiful couples Alyssa and Duncan so
Duncan's Mr Handsome yes he's got a set
of ears on him yeah he's handsome as
hell okay Alyssa is his Mormon bride yes
who's shy like everything is just like
she's so shy and they've just been the
perfect couple they've been the best
couple of the whole thing are they
boring so boring oh but okay you have to
love their love okay
it's [__] real bro it's real bro and
they were horny for ages before they
banged he couldn't handle it anymore and
she couldn't handle it anymore yeah they
went to it they went to it they went to
it anyway sexy it was
um so they're perfect perfect now
there's Adam stuff come out
doesn't play this cheat in game bro I
swear to God you would have thought she
was the one that got cheated on yep she
made it more about her than it was about
Janelle yep she came in there said I
can't wait till Claire comes in there
[__] [__]
she best she best not trying I'm just
I'm gonna stand up when she gets me I'm
saying it's not silent bro do you know
the one who's been betrayed Janelle's
decided like yeah yeah she was like [__]
Claire Bro [__] like [__] Adam [__] all
these man like I'm done with this bro
I'm not chatting to them and Duncan's
trying to say look not gonna lie to you
Adam's my boy I hate what he did but
he's still my boy I don't rate him for
this Behavior but like I'm not I'm not
gonna tell you that I'm never gonna chat
to him again and she was like are you
stupid bruv she literally was in and
saying are you stupid bro you're gonna
chat to my man you're condoning his
behavior he's like no I'm not I just
don't hate his entire life and write him
out my life because he cheated on his
girl bro like two days into the
experiment yeah yeah like come on you're
being ridiculous and she was like you're
being crazy bro he needs to get burned
of the steak oh she's zero or a hundred
she's one of them she doesn't play this
game okay you think he was a murderer
yeah oh wow and he's like I'm not on
this stuff you're on Ultimate spoke it's
not even anything to do with us yeah
like chill out imagine if it was him bro
imagine if it was you would kill him in
fact if it was Duncan I promise you
she'll kill him bro she'll skin him
alive so there's a little bit of beef
between them yeah and I'm interested to
see what they're saying on the
commitment ceremony because they've
never had any friction at all they've
been perfect boring perfect every time
okay something's happening between
Cameron and uh Lindell behind the scenes
I don't know what's going on yeah
they're a bit messy yeah so they keep
coming back together they're together
they've been another Power couple she's
the one that's just coughing up stuff
and might die but she's got a miracle
Drive okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah her
lungs are marked yeah
um what's that what's the thing again
fibrosis
so they've been perfect all the way they
had a little bit of friction because
again she can't keep her mouth shut and
he's like stop bringing smoke to
everyone mind your business sometimes
you don't have to get involved in
everyone's beef all the time me and you
are here every week or beef you're in
this you've got something to say you've
got this tea that you need to spill
every week is a new team yeah little
please yeah it's them or me he said is
there more me bro she said it's my girl
I'm not gonna say nothing he's like she
already knows bro yeah yeah leave it
yeah so anyway without a bear friction
but then they made up but then this week
they're coming to the ceremony they're
just not chatting
um and he's I'm in the doghouse but no
one knows why so I'm intrigued to see
how that develops okay
now
Adam Jesse had the chat Claire's had
their chat everyone else all good
there's something that's going to cook
up next week with Dan I don't know what
it is but something Penny drops with Dan
and then okay yeah and then the only new
couple that we've got is Evelyn who's
done with dance with sandy sandy okay
yeah yeah I heard a rumor that is
something to do with a butt dial or
something like that and one of the new
husbands is Ops and baited out Dan
saying that he was like showing off his
exes or something yeah yeah
Rupert new new yeah yeah yeah nervous
Rupert nervous Rupert apparently butt
dialed his Mrs Evelyn and she overheard
basically
Dan just slew in Sandy also Hugo slew in
Taylor
she does she needs to get that's
understandable so when he got the grief
for that I was a bit like well that's
just understandable but yeah Dan Sandy's
he was showing pictures of his ex saying
this is his type Sandy's not his type oh
no basically yeah she's just not it and
he butt dialed Evelyn and Rupert is
supposed to apparently butt dialed
Evelyn it's a 2023 my God there's no
such thing as Batman we are not yeah you
know what Harrison was actually calling
that out yeah he was saying you know
what I don't believe it I sit straight
up there's no sort of thing I don't
think he'd I don't think yeah I what I
think happened was Rupert
I think Rupert might have butt dialed
and if he did uh his wife Evelyn only
heard a little bit okay when he got back
to Evelyn oh he spilled auditing I
reckon he was wasted and she made him
spill it oh okay that's what I think
okay if there was a butt dial at all but
she would say all the details that
Evelyn's got from this apparent butt
dial it would be like my man basically
phoned him phoned her and I put a phone
yeah
I don't know man I don't know yeah okay
so LSL SLS anyway so the new couple I'm
excited to hear about that cool because
Dan's been in Clear Water he had a
little bit shaking us with Harrison's
false accusations he's been juicy water
since then okay cool
next up is the new couple Rupa and
Evelyn yep Evelyn oh she's a buddy you
know the Asian body you said yeah yeah
she's more than bad bro let me pray
she's more than bad okay what's her name
is
Evelyn and you'll know yeah I typed in
Evie it was the first thing that came
out all my life she is Evelyn
she is banging bro she's very good
looking who's that who's her man bro she
rocked up to the altar my man couldn't
speak he was shaking bro his face was
bright red he was shaking sweating
shaking couldn't hold the Rings couldn't
do nothing or the other man would have
been pissed oh fine when she came into
the dinner party Harrison tried not to
laugh bro he would didn't send her and
his face was like
because she's too fire and she wants to
bang her man
but he's too scared bro
so he went on the honeymoon yeah she's
like oh it's chilly in here come you
know from on a wedding day he's not
speaking about nothing and she's like
I'm trying to find out if he's on it or
not and she didn't even fancy him like
that but she's like I'm in this
experiment bro yeah let me try something
so she was like do you want to lips me
for the for the photo okay and he was
like
[__] she said pick me up hold me carry
me he's like
thumb nervous moving nervous they get
back to the hotel she says it's chilly
in it let's run a hot bath rose petals
in there bikini on slides in the boxes
get in
and he's does he go and he gets in
nervous and he's in there for two
minutes he's like maybe we should get
out
wasted opportunity he massages her she
gets butt naked massage Ting yeah he
starts he gets the hot oil like squirts
it on her back she's like rub me he gets
that little Banana Leaf and just starts
smacking her back
he goes oh you don't want your ass Rob
do you yeah and she's like what he's
like now you don't want your ass rubbed
and then just keep smacking over the
[__] he's a man he's a man and she's
saying I'm giving him everything and
she's like I don't think he understands
how much I'm giving him because once I
turn it off oh he'll he'll know yeah
she's so fire damn
Foo head you're not listening to me
she's so funny Instagram she's banging
bro she's banging
he made a little joke in his vows like
my mom's happy that I made it this far
without sex before marriage or something
like that okay he made a little joke but
to be his his vows were janky bro yeah
he was trying to he was trying to bust
joke and nothing was landed nothing was
landed he kept saying all this rubbish
one and then you move on to the next
joke
it was the worst experience live TV yeah
yeah about I was oh she's rough if he is
a virgin then obviously explains a lot
I'll explain to everything bro and if he
is he can't handle that kind of work
yeah that's too much yeah I need it
Level Playing yeah yeah I need a Level
Playing Field bro yeah she's 10 steps
ahead like yeah she yeah he can't handle
that um yeah she's Fire Man Jesus
um but yeah she I I swear she's
definitely gonna cause a rocker son
Harris is going to try and move to us
yeah I can see one of them moving to her
like when they have a rocky situation
with that thing try and consoler yeah
yeah oh they're waiting for her and
Rupert domestic yeah yeah
and she can't go she can't go to dinner
tables and say he's not banging me the
way I want to be banged Harrison I hear
stuff like that he can't I promise you
bro I was the third man in that group
they can't hear stuff like that they'll
find any excuse any excuse lucky
Shannon's not here because he would have
been like this is the thing you should
have matched me with I would never chat
to my ex this is the [__] you should
have matched me with bro yeah
Jesus bro she's stunning that's jokes
yeah anyway yeah um that's that's that's
my upside a minute I'm I'm excited for
the Nexus there's a couple new beef
that's cooking up carpool new beefs that
are going to be cooking up so I'm ready
and thank you to everyone who sent me a
link for stuff without ads um they were
sending me this dodge Australian links I
haven't clicked a single one yeah but I
appreciate the effort yeah and I'll do
my own due diligence
but yeah yeah dodgy link somebody okay
saying no as no ads so yeah I'm looking
forward to checking that out okay cool
man right we've got a dilemma to finish
this off today am I the uh this one's
gonna piss you off am I the [__] fee
in the toppings of my boyfriend's Pizza
earlier today to hear the rest of this
yeah God earlier tonight I ordered
Hawaiian pizza with my boyfriend we've
only been dating for a month so it's the
first time I ate pizza with him we only
finished about half and then went to
watch TV I was still hungry so I ate all
the toppings off the pizza
when he saw it he absolutely flipped out
he said that he was saving it for lunch
tomorrow thanks he had never met anyone
who would do anything like this and he
was genuinely upset
I thought he was joking and I laughed it
off but it's been a couple hours and
he's still upset he's talking about how
he was looking forward to having it his
leftovers for lunch and now I've and now
I have ruined his lunch I've offered to
buy him a new pizza but he kept saying
it wasn't about that and it's just
ruined my day is he overreacting or am I
the [__] fam
straight off the Jump you're not only
the [__] you're crazy you're the
biggest [__] don't
top it off the pizza so it's just
Marguerite it's just margarites were
dense
nah bro you're criminal so she's
individually yams pineapple and yum yeah
just pineapple ham pineapple ham just
leaving up dents in my margarita yeah
are you a gerbil yes
permission just started it's been a
month
you've seen Flags already yeah that's a
scene of flags I've never met anyone
that would do this yeah I've never heard
of such pain again I've actually never
heard of soccer he's gonna buy you a new
one it's not about that she was doing
you must be joking I was late so few
minutes chicks will try to play that
cute [__] yeah they all try and play
that cool [__] like it's just it's all
jokes it has to be a joke it's me we're
talking about it has to be it has to be
a joke too cute for him put your hands
up yeah
bro
[Laughter]
that's disgraceful disgraceful behavior
um I have never heard anything like it
and I pray it doesn't happen to anyone I
know because yeah I wouldn't wish that
on anyone yeah that's just thanking the
whole topic that's a cause for a fight
she knew what she was doing when she
integrated that literally bro she didn't
scared that's of course that's crazy
chat because you can't eat that anymore
you can't bro you actually rather order
a fresh Margarita than eat that Rags
right because I'm still got pineapple
and ham residue all over the place
it's just orangey little bits of juice
on it and it's just like what even is
that I need to taste the whole pineapple
also who orders Hawaiian bro I've had in
Hawaiian since I was probably a kid I've
had it once I'm
wow literally who what is Hawaiian why
did you stop do you order Hawaiian no
he does oh my God you do wait is that
your favorite pizza no it's fine no it's
not my favorite I thought you were yeah
he thought he was agreeing bro I saw the
miscommunication I saw it with my own
eyes oh wait he saw him not
him not he was not in for obviously not
he was and then as soon as he heard REM
yeah as soon as heard Rems say obviously
not he looked down his Notepad
hey look I saw the whole thing
and I'm sick of being a black sheep
that's why he said nothing I don't want
to talk about it
that's hilarious what's your what's your
go-to pizza bar Hawaiian I like the uh
Texas barbecue yes
it's a bit too strong for me yeah I get
the same but I take it without the bacon
I was about to say the Bacon's too much
I swapped that [__] out for pepperoni
It's gotta be barbecue base though fats
yeah I get a little hot and spicy thing
is that what what's that chicken and
it's uh um what's that nice
um what is it sometimes it depends if
we're doing dominoes or not I think it's
chicken red and green peppers and
jalapenos sounds Banks yeah sounds buff
it bangs with that that dip Domino's
please don't need to sip the dip game up
bro with that garlic and whatever garlic
and herb garlic herb dip on Domino's
yeah bro it's not to be messed with them
these times they're offering you that
fat pot the big pot yeah yeah
you can douse yourself yeah you can
drink that
you can drink that this was awesome
these are begging for it
and they give you some dirty garlic
thing man in the same like
um like ketchup thingy oh yeah yeah
who's that who's that feeding that's not
getting me through one crust yes what's
your what's your go-to pizza
[Music]
um
um definitely a barbecue chicken um
actually double up on that with the
barbecue base as well agreed with the uh
no bacon facts yeah yeah Bacon's ruin a
piece for everyone yeah it is that's
yeah that's me but yeah definitely it's
me Feast esque kind of barbecue base
yeah man barbecue base
um not always not on the hot space
always man because sometimes sometimes
it's just a bit much
um sometimes it's too sweet and too
smoky this is a pizza we're talking
about it's delicate you know what I mean
sometimes a barbecue is just too strong
bro I love I love barbecue baseball I
loved it I tend to only get the same
thing I don't if I'm getting for example
like you said the hot and spicy I've
never had hot and spicy with barbecue
base I wouldn't dare so I'd probably get
as a as a regular as well sometimes I
don't like sometimes you have to trust
the the the recipe the recipe
for reasons Original Barbecue base in it
what is sorry he faces his barbecue base
originally isn't it I think it is yeah
so that's why I'm used to that one yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta trust it
yeah yeah sometimes sometimes people go
into restaurants and they're like can I
have this but get rid of this can I have
this instead and I'm like don't insult
the share facts taste it how it's
supposed to be tasted sometimes bro and
then judge from there and then just from
there the next time we can free it up
because he doesn't always do it but
anyway right we're gonna lock it there
guys don't be taking toppings off
people's pizza that's cause for concerns
facts even if it is Hawaiian even if it
is
you say some stuff on this podcast bro
I'm so happy we have you but Jesus I'm
actually happy about the mics knows
um but anyways thank you thank you thank
you um catch us on Thursday patreon.com
and as always love love love
[Music]
foreign